sobre el mandato judicial que agudiza la
crisis de la libertad de expresión en
Guatemala ha habido varias reacciones la
primera de ellas es la del propio
implicado el periodista José Rubén
Zamora quien ayer saliendo de la torre
de tribunales en ciudad de Guatemala
adujo que es completamente falso que él
sea un tipo de coordinador de la
conspiración de un grupo de gente de
prensa para destruir o atacar a los
jueces y Fiscales ahora bien localmente
la asociación de periodistas de
Guatemala fue más vehemente y dijo que
tanto el Ministerio Público o la
fiscalía así como varios jueces y
Fiscales de Guatemala están trabajando y
aquí abro comillas como Sepultureros de
la Democracia cierro comillas
internacionalmente el centro para los
periodistas con sede en Washington dijo
que Guatemala está cerca a un
autoritarismo y también con sede en
Washington la organización de Human
Rights dijo que está siguiendo con
profunda y enorme preocupación esta
decisión de la fiscal Cintia monterroso
de investigar a nueve periodistas y
columnistas sobre el caso de un otro
periodista que es José Rubén Zamora
fuerte crítico de Alejandro yamate y que
de pronto en estas publicaciones
habrían inferido que la justicia en
Guatemala está siendo intervenida por el
ejecutivo del presidente Andrés y recién
cumplidos los siete meses de prisión
cómo avanza el juicio de José Rubén
Zamora
Andrés para muchas organizaciones
internacionales de Derechos Humanos así
como de libertad de prensa el caso de
José Rubén Zamora quien ya cumple 7
meses en prisiones completamente Injusto
a él inicialmente se le acusó por tres
delitos el lavado de dinero tráfico de
influencias chantaje y el fiscal que lo
llevó a investigación Rafael currucciche
valga aclarar que es un fiscal que está
señalado en la lista Engel de los
Estados Unidos como un actor que no
favorece la anticorrupción pues le dijo
que lo investigarían por su calidad de
empresario más nueve periodista y es que
como periodista este José Rubén Zamora
que fundó el periódico pues ha destapado
escándalos múltiples de corrupción en
este país centroamericano que han
llevado a prisión a tres presidentes
Álvaro Colón
también Alfonso Portillo así como Otto
Pérez Molina yamaté y no iba a ser la
excepción del blanco de sus
investigaciones para muchos el hecho de
que él se encuentre preso Pues aduce a
una revancha del ejecutivo y muchos
esperan es que las próximas elecciones
cambian el destino del presidente para
que pueda haber Justicia con este
periodista